I've made a few vlog type videos
recently and I really like the concept
of recording aspects of your life
regardless of whether people view it or
not I feel like recording your life
through the vlog form that's become more
popular it's something that I really
appreciate I often think it's kind of a
shame that we lose so much of our life
through not recording it to me the idea
of memory is such a huge component of
who we are one of my biggest fears is
losing my memories because I feel like
that is losing Who I am the memories
that I have define what I like and what
I do and I feel like they're the essence
of my personality I only remember a
fraction of the things that happened to
me
and I wonder does that make me only kind
of a fraction of Who I am is it really a
shame that I lose so much of my life I
actually kind of like the idea of
recording every part of your life and
sort of that sci-fi sense or following
being followed around with a 360 camera
and being able to log memories as they
really happened this concept was
explored in a recent episode of the show
black mirror and in the episode a guy
has through a implant in his eye the
ability to record everything that
happens and to sift through the memories
at first I'm like oh that's so awesome
what happens in this show without too
many spoilers is that he kind of goes
mad from the idea of having that ability
to relive everything whether it's a good
or a horrible experience I guess that's
the natural conclusion of the idea that
we wouldn't be able to handle recording
everything that there are things better
left forgotten that purging our minds is
the only way we can continue to live and
go forwards but I also think the episode
was a little bit unfair to the idea they
sort of jump straight to the conclusion
that this is going to be bad without
really showing how it can change the
fundamental way we live our lives I
don't deny that it would probably be a
bad idea to be able to remember
everything I'm certainly sure there are
things I'm glad I've forgotten but I
still like the idea or at least the idea
of recording a little bit more but is
this a totally mad idea I'm not sure
that let me know would you want to
record aspects of your life maybe even
not for your own use but just as sort of
a digital immortality